our draft for today the best number two
receivers in the nfl this could get
interesting because
first you have to you know have an idea
of what a number two receiver is who the
number two receivers are
which creates some opportunities for
challenge flags chris i'll go ahead and
give you the first pick in this one well
number two receivers
first what i knew but you're right
that's a good question i think
i mean because like you you we could
throw out a team i'm gonna throw it out
there i don't care if you pick them or
not
but let's just say the los angeles rams
they got robert woods
and cooper cup i know who's the one
who's the two i would argue both are
twos
really you know in the realm of the nfl
but
i guess in the spirit of the draft we're
gonna say one's a one and one's a two so
we'll see where it goes i'm not going
there even though i think they're
phenomenal football players
my best number three receive your pick
my best number two wide receiver will be
jarvis landry i think that's the best
number two receiver in football he's
such a good number two you're not sure
he might be a number one
but he's not a number one with the
cleveland browns it's odell beckham jr
okay he is the guy that garners the most
attention
and is the superstar of that team but
jarvis landry i mean come on he does
everything
you know can run the football speed
sweeps catch screens break tackles make
people miss
you know and then within the number two
receiver we usually think like slot
you know oh he can work the middle of
the field to do all things all those
things yeah
he's as good as it gets in that
department let alone he's really got
enough talent to line up outside and be
a dangerous guy there too
so uh as far as that's concerned i think
jarvis landry is the best number two in
this sport
all right let me ask you this question
who would you rather have on your team
jarvis landry or sammy watkins
oh i i like guys that stay healthy
so i know you're gonna take sammy
watkins but i like guys that are healthy
that would be my argument trust me sammy
was my thought there
so you going sammy i'm going sammy i
mean the guy was the fourth overall pick
in the draft
in the same year that otto beckham jr
the number one receiver in cleveland was
drafted now watkins has never lived up
to that status
but he's found his niche in kansas city
as the number two to tyree kill
because he's got number one receiver
skills
in a number two receiver's body that's
what makes him in my mind the best
number two receiver in the nfl
he's really not a number two receiver
he's a cone number one but then again
tyree kill's so good
you can't be number one you can't even
be code number one
with tyree kill around so he's number
two just by virtue of the fact of how
good tyree kill is so they're both so
good
give me tyree kills number two receiver
sami watch
yeah i get it it's the same premise of
the guys i just talked about
yeah landry and odell they're both
number ones really but i understand
you know my picks better i mean you're
only going to get your guy for four
games i'm getting mine for 16. so i like
my pick better
um okay pick number two is going to be
i'm going to the team we just talked
about and your power rankings
i'm going with mike williams yeah los
angeles chargers
he's a guy that i don't know we just
seem to never really talk about
but huge body can make some plays happen
after the catch
i mean one of the better 50 50 high
point
receivers in all the football and you
talk about big
plays you know they have a number one
yen keenan allen
who's not a big play guy he's gonna work
the intermediate routes and get a lot of
five and eight and ten and twelve yard
catches
mike williams is the one that gets the
big plays i mean
this stat line is kind of like crazy
when you look at it 49
receptions for a thousand and one yards
last year
20.4 yards per you know reception
i mean that that's pretty amazing to say
that yeah a guy that's not getting a ton
of balls come his way when they do come
his way
they're game-changing type plays so uh
mike williams going to be my second pick
see this is one where you stray i think
a little too close to the sun on wings
of pastrami because
you could argue he's the number one with
the chargers
you are now that was number two and then
you argue that with him on twitter
because i don't think he's
i'm not picking it i can tell you that
mike williams is number
one remember i know remember our
argument for keenan allen not being a
top 10 guy
if you don't command double coverage
you're not a top 10 guy
we need to look at the chargers film to
resolve this and see who gets doubled
between the two
the guy who gets doubled is the number
one the guy who doesn't is the number
two
and maybe it's interchangeable i don't
know and i'm not going to pretend to
know
but to me that that's why i stayed away
from that one because i'm looking for a
clear number one
clear number two here's a clear number
two even though we don't know who the
number one
is we talked about this earlier in the
week juju's miss schuster is the
consummate he is the perfect he is the
ideal
number two receiver in the national
football league the problem is last year
the steelers tried to make him number
one yeah and it didn't work
confirming that he is the perfect number
two receiver now they just have to find
a number one receiver
who will command the double coverage and
stretch the field and let juju smith
schuster
be that same kind of player that jarvis
landry is for the browns
be that reliable target who catches
everything but doesn't take the top off
the defense
he was the mvp of the team in 2018 for a
reason
of course one of the reasons was that
antonio brown was taking all the
attention away from him that's one of
the reasons why antonio stormed out
week 17 once he found out that juju was
the team mvp and not him so give me juju
schmidt schuster
even though we don't know who the number
one we see we need to
we need can we call 345 park ave and get
al riverrun on the phone please i got a
challenge flag here
i don't know if we can say this is the
number two receiver i mean in theory
you're right he's a number two receiver
to give you a hard time for the draft
he's the number one guy in the steelers
right now and you know i think you're
really moving the line there
really moving the line okay
man i didn't think this guy was going to
be on the board here honestly but i got
to go chris godwin for the
the tampa bay buccaneers i i got you
know i honestly i didn't even think i
was going to be able to pick him here
um but hey yeah when you're one of the
you know arguably one of the best slot
receivers in football got good
size everything like that a big part of
the offense yeah we know mike evans is
the main guy there he's the one that
attracts
the true double team he is a mike evans
is a true number one i don't think
you're gonna argue
that uh but but chris chris godwin you
know a guy that really jumped on the
scene last year and i think he's gonna
have an even bigger role this year
because of some of the brady influence
and those new england type plays
that edelman got all these years you'll
see chris godwin but uh i i think he is
clearly one of the best number twos in
football
yeah i i don't disagree with that and i
thought about taking him instead of juju
but my point is that juju is the ideal
number two guy
yeah he's just not on a team where he
potentially will have the luxury
to be number two all right uh this can
go a lot of different directions and
there are some great numbers
receivers out there we're gonna have to
mention some of them on the way out to
minimize the attacks that we absorb on
social media
i am torn here but i tell you what i got
to go with larry fitzgerald
i have to deandre hopkins becomes the
clear-cut number one i mean you could
argue christian kirk's the number two
yeah arizona that's what i was gonna say
but i
i you know fitzgerald had more
production last year at least in
receiving yardage and
and and he's still look there's been
this vague sense the last five years
that he's going to retire even though he
hasn't quite done the full-blown brett
favre of will i or won't i retire i
don't know why there's been this nagging
sense
he's gonna walk away he still keeps
going and he still keeps performing he
still keeps producing
and he's never had a guy like deandre
hopkins to take
attention away from him the way that
hopkins will
i am very excited to see what larry
fitzgerald will do this year
with kyle murray throwing the ball with
deandre hopkins attracting double
coverage
all the time and one of the best
receivers in nfl history who still is in
position
to leave with every record if he plays
long enough
what can he do this year in that offense
yeah i mean he's not falling off the
cliff that's for sure i mean he's kind
of like the tom brady of wide receivers
he's showing everybody oh you want to
play a long time in a position where you
need to be explosive and things like
that he's showing how to do it
you know it's pretty damn impressive you
know again
yeah he's the number two i'll give you
that for now i think it's gonna end up
being christian kirk
when when all said and done uh but but i
i think you're right i think we
legitimately call him the two
you know borderline three your draft
very suspect today i mean you picked the
number one
a guy that plays four games and then a
borderline number three receiver
who used to be a superstar number one
but either way
what other guys i needed you to i needed
you to get out of this week without
being crushed every single day
emmanuel sanders yeah the number two to
michael thomas
right marvin jones definitely in detroit
michael gallup
tyler lockett yeah seattle sure you're
number one in seattle
is it dk metcalf or tyler it's why i
stayed away i mean i i g
i think it's i think it's tyler lockett
right now right i mean i think dk
metcalf's the new go-to
superstar guy i think he proved that at
the end of the season you know yeah
those i had all those guys on the list
you're right i even had robbie anderson
with the carolina panthers behind dj
moore
you know i mean we kind of forgot about
him in that off-season acquisition but
uh i think we hit the john brown the
number two up in buffalo now pretty damn
good player too behind
stefan diggs so uh yeah there's some
good ones out there
i thought about rolling the dice on
jerry judy as well i know
he's gonna be the number two right but
he's unproven how about dallas i
mentioned michael gallup
i know number two
i was going to be cute and like almost
take them as both like at one point in
the draft i thought
maybe i'll just say both of these guys
names because i'm not sure who is going
to be two but
whoever it is they're in good shape you
know across the board at receiver in
dallas i'd like to be dak prescott this
year
al shawn jeffrey if and when he's
healthy enough to play he's a great
number two
to desean jackson if and when he's
healthy enough to ever play
and you know this whole thing was
premised on calvin ridley's comments
and that's the first time his name came
out
i know he he he's still he's a guy that
we could have picked too
he is and he is a guy that i think you
know out of the number twos who has a
chance to be
still the number one too like he could
be that guy and going it's still early
on in his career and yeah you're behind
julio jones who's one of the greatest
receivers in the history of football
first ballot hall of famer so it's hard
to be a number one on that team when
that guy's still the main focus
and one guy we didn't mention that i
think we should justin jefferson the
vikings first round pick he's the number
two to adam thielen
and the thing is as the season goes on
if jefferson lives up to his potential
at some point this year or next year
he's the number one he could be the one
so
he he could be so good as the number two
he takes out because adam thielen feels
more like he should be a number two he's
not the guy who's going to stretch the
field that's the way stefan diggs did
and
when it was diggs and thielen thielen
was number two
and i think one of the reasons why diggs
maybe wanted out was
thielen ended up with a better contract
than the number one receiver in
minnesota stefan diggs at least the
number one
previously now it could be justin
jefferson in time but for now
it's adam feeling hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports